this is what streets across thailand
should look like this week
here locals and tourists in bangkok's
backpacking hub of khao san road out in
mass
celebrating the thai songkran new year
with parties and water fights
but on khao san road this year and
nationwide the party
has been cancelled a recent spike in
covid cases thought to have started at
nightlife spots in bangkok has
raced across the country thailand has
been viewed as a covet success story
with low infection rates
but now a third wave is here throwing
cold water on the hopes of many in the
tourist and hospitality industry
just as it was positioning for a rebound
bee has run her hair braiding shop along
khao san road for so long
she doesn't even remember when she
started as she relies on backpacking
tours she might have to close for good
yeah this is a very tiring time
after the first outbreak i still had
some savings left
after the second outbreak things got a
little bit better
but the latest wave is looking like the
worst i don't know what to do
despite the dim outlook some are still
setting up for songkran but
without the celebrations what's deeply
concerning to health officials about
this new wave
is that some of the cases have the
highly transmissible uk variant
and this week has seen the largest daily
infection rates of the pandemic
new patients from this third wave are
mainly from bangkok's middle class
with the capability to move around our
concern is the quarantine and isolation
of new patients
hospitals are running out of space when
the first clusters were discovered the
need for testing was so great
many private hospitals ran out of covid
testing supplies
prime minister tenocha announced that
there would not be a national lockdown
but each province could decide
entry restrictions his government
directly hit by the new wave at least
five cabinet members are now in
quarantine including the minister of
health
only about 500 000 doses of covet
vaccines have been given to the
population of
69 million people some in the opposition
see the lagging vaccination program as
one of multiple failings by the
administration
they really underestimated the severity
of the crisis and failed on sourcing
more vaccine options
they did not continue with covet
readiness set at the beginning of the
pandemic
they were not ready to immediately
respond to this wave
wishing that next year songkran will
again look like it's supposed to
most ties will be closely watching the
infection rates over the next two weeks
hoping there won't be a spike after
everyone returns to work
after the holiday raising the
possibility of a happier new year
scott heidler al jazeera bangkok